[Music]
today on drew the one and only
oprah winfrey this is because of you
drew
[Applause]
you have changed my life we all
thrive in this world through friendship
gail was my calming safe place
makes me want to cry now thinking about
it it all starts now
please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
right back at you guys hello vff
we have a very special guest today i'm
going to get right into it
she doesn't need an introduction it's
the one and only
oprah winfrey
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
this is the loudest we've been since we
started in august
just us in a very big room kind of uh
starting in an unprecedented time um
welcome to the show
dare i say maybe you've seen it
yes i have and may i say dare i say
seeing it actually changed my life you
have changed
my life you certainly changed my work
life because i was there for that very
first show where you beamed in
cameron and there you all were and we
were
you know didn't know that you all
weren't in the same space
i watched that and i said hey
why can't we do what drew did and since
why can't we do what you did and since
that time
for oprah conversations for apple tv
i the first time i did it was with
president barack obama talking about his
book promised land
and there we were sitting right across
from each other
in my living room in front of the
fireplace and i
i said then this is because of you drew
so thank you
i am a woman
i have to thank you so much because you
didn't need to give us the credit
but you did and for those who are not
aware here's a little
taped piece on the technology of which
oprah and i are talking about
when we launched this show in the middle
of a pandemic
we had to get creative with the magic of
technology we came up with a way
to transport our guests from our la
studio
right here to new york how cool is that
we knew
one person who thought so too it's oprah
it's oprah it's oprah oh bro
um yes the oprah was inspired to use a
similar green screen technology to
interview guests like president barack
obama
listen we may not be able to be in the
same room
but we can sure feel like it and look
like it
i thank you so much
because i i'm i'm gonna be really honest
i haven't really admitted this uh out
loud but
it was really scary for me to be
you know a girl a woman i don't know
what i am
a female asking for people to take this
risk
and spend this money and ask ourselves
these questions and i'm so
grateful to my bosses that they allowed
us to do this because this was
you know a check and a risk away from
not
happening and i want to ask you
is this where we're going the water's
out of the bottle people are not going
to travel the way they used to
people have gotten comfortable with
interview styles
some are going to show up some aren't
you're going to have access to more
people than you ever did
in some ways because the technology it's
all going to be maybe a mixed bag
and if it is don't we have to make it
the best and most compelling
television in honor of the audience yeah
i
one thousand percent agree with that and
i think that's why i say you really
you literally have changed my life and
when people say that i said because
listen
after drew i'm not going nowhere and so
the truth is you're able to have better
access
and i think there will certainly be
times in
both of our lives and in our careers
when being directly in front of the
person
makes a a world of difference and may
may be necessary but i think that
in terms of having access to anybody in
the world
at any time what you all did in that
first show
um lit the path for changing it forever
and i'm sure we would have done it today
but i you know i'm where there's no
studio so i'm like in the middle of
nowhere out here you need a studio to be
able to do it
you really do there was a studio within
500 miles i would have done it
i'm so glad and may we do it again in
the future
because i was so glad to see
you embracing this you acknowledging us
and us moving forward in this way
because
it does become a new normal and it for
the girl
who felt really honestly again this is
the part
i don't talk about is when you're
fighting for things in business
it's not comfortable especially when
they're not
done you feel like the messy one you
feel like the one who might be
spending people's money in a improper
way you don't know if the risk is going
to pay off but you get into your
convictions and you fight for them
and so when i saw you embracing the
technology it told
that person who hung up the phone that
day because i remember saying listen you
guys
we have got to do this we have got to
find a new way for our future
of television this is not funny we are
in a really unprecedented time
and we can't go on with the home show
forever we just can't
you did the thing that i had to do a
thousand times over the years and when i
first started
uh so let me applaud you for doing the
thing
that every person particularly every
woman
needs to learn as soon as possible your
gut is right for
you so when you feel something in your
gut
and you think wow i need to i need to
really move on that
that means it is right for you
it doesn't mean that is is right for
everybody else and i think
it takes women in particularly a long
long time
to be affirmed in their own beliefs and
that is the reason
actually we were the number one talk
show for 25
years is because i all it always came
back to
what do i feel what do i feel is
my real intention in doing this and i
cannot do it if it's not true to me
even if everybody else says and many
times you know producers would come in
with ideas and i would say
i can't do that i don't i don't i don't
know how i can sit in that chair
and keep a straight face and do that and
do that
i'm not gonna be able to do that so you
you i applaud you
for going with your gut because your gut
is always right for you
well i think you've given so much
courage to everyone
um especially women to fight
for what we believe in and i
was going to ask you if you had any
advice may i ask
when you ended your first season and you
knew you were rounding the corner
into season two what were you telling
yourself
i actually was telling myself uh
self you was right because
as uh most people don't know this now
but
when we launched in 1986
i had been a local talk show in chicago
for two years what i understood was
that there's a commonality in our human
experience
and that people are no different in
chicago than they are in new york than
they are
in idaho than they are in rhode island
when it comes to the core
now we're in you know everybody's so
divided about their politics and their
beliefs and so forth
but i i still do believe at the core we
are all the same
if you ask blue state red states purple
states
what really matters to you the answer is
is the same people care about their
families they care about being able to
live decent lives they care about being
able to do that in comfort and do that
with
a sense of peace and um i i still
think in spite of all the craziness in
spite of all the divisions which is what
what everybody talks about
all the time is that we are they're we
are more alike than we are different
which is a
very famous maya angelou line she used
to say that all the time
and in our humanness we are we all are
just seeking the same things
and that's what this platform the drew
barrymore show offers
every day is a chance for those of us of
like-mindedness
those of us who are seeking the joy who
wants to wear some bows
i went extra jaunty for you i was like
bones and flowers it's oprah
like i'm surprised i don't have bells on
and like
a boa when we come back even more
with oprah don't go anywhere
[Music]
what i realized is that gail was my
regulation makes me want to cry now
thinking about it
and is still the person in my life i
have
probably three people in my life who are
going to tell me the truth no matter
what
here's the bottom line that really was
the hugest
epiphany for me
welcome back we are here with oprah
winfrey
i'm doing drew i'm doing drew right now
i just
hi gail
yeah she's saying hi she's saying hi to
you
i i just want to say i think that three
of us should get together you know
i'm i think that would be so much fun
yes when this pancake mix is over let's
make sure that happens drew all right
gayle i'll talk to you later
[Laughter]
you know we all i think thrive in this
world through friendship
you know a lot of you know children and
marriages they
you know the friends were there at the
beginning
they'll be there till the end they're
these sort of lifelong relationships
it's different than blood family it's
choice
but it feels as intimate and loyal and
your friendship with gail has been
something that you know we all
aspired to because we want that kind of
friendship in our life
and by the way you now have oprah daily
which
i happen to mention to gail that i
thought that the oprah daily the daily
word it's so
brilliant well thank you thank you i
wanted
i i i actually came up with that because
i wanted it to be
what i realized is that the oprah show
was a habit just like the drew barrymore
show
people are creating a habit around that
and that's what you want
that's your core viewer that's who
you're speaking to every day
and the idea of having a
daily inspiration point a daily quote
a daily something that you can rely on
to give you just a little lift you know
my whole goal throughout my life even
before i could articulate it
is how do you bring a light into
people's lives
how do you let them see the best of
themselves how do you
allow them to grow into becoming more of
who they
are which is what every one of us is
actually aspiring to do whether you can
articulate that for yourself
or not you just you just want to become
more more solid
you want to have the ability to have the
fullest expression of yourself
as a human being and you do that
by by habits by by rituals by
creating a space where you can give back
to yourself in a way that allows you to
flourish so
we we are growing it into what
i know will be in the future is a daily
spot of inspiration for everybody so
thank you for mentioning that
we need you on the daily i listen to
your serious xm channel through both my
pregnancies
and i it was it was my daily
north star it was my daily fix thank you
for that
it's true i'll never forget the story
you told about gail getting the water
for the traffic cop and how that
moment was her being such an important
and good parent to her son
because she was showing him the kind of
person to be and that gave me hope
because
i felt so lost like what blueprint do i
have to pull on to become a parent
i was scared out of my mind and i
thought hearing that story
if i can be an example to my kids maybe
i don't have to draw from my past or
even
fight it i can try to be myself
and that can that can
give me hope to be a good parent that
story literally changed my life it was
um
so thank you for that well you know gail
is to date
and she always says well all parents do
then i'll pass i don't know they don't
gail is to date the best model
parent i have ever seen i've never seen
anybody who
was more engaged
more respectful of her children
and when she first had kids you know
because we were best friends in
in in met at a television station
baltimore
and once she married and had kids i
thought well there's going to be
distance in our relationship because
she's not going to have time to
you know devote to to our friendship
and it that did not happen but what did
happen
every time she was on the phone with me
and one of her children
entered the room she would stop she
would put the phone down
even if she didn't put the phone down
they would be acknowledged
she was present there for them she would
say mommy's on the phone now with annie
oh
and morning bear he calls kirby bear
morning she
there was an acknowledgement and and and
what i would have to say over the years
a mutual respect and i know we're going
to be talking later about the subject of
what happened to you but one of the
things that dr perry says in this book
is that when children grow up and they
realize that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents it changes who they
are
what your kids want and this is actually
true of everybody
they they want to know that you are that
you're here that you see me
that you see me and you hear me and that
i matter to you
and that is true for everybody else in
your life too
we're gonna get even more personal with
oprah stay right here
[Music]
[Applause]
we are back with the one and only oprah
winfrey
speaking of this extraordinary book that
i've been reading
um and i will forever have the chart
um that dr perry uh put in the book as
far as
the upside down triangle the upside down
triangle what you guys talk about
as far as the impression that children
are left with at such an earlier age
than i think
was spoken about in at least
my growing up i i think even
into almost having kids i feel like
everybody kind of went
they won't notice when they're when
they're young and i i
i did not understand why that was the
notion it didn't seem right it didn't
feel right
but i wanted to believe it because
that's what so many people had said
here's the bottom line that really was
the hugest
epiphany for me all these years i've
done
multiple shows where people say
exactly what you just said drew oh they
won't remember
uh you know i'm yes i'm in an abusive
relationship and as soon as
you know uh the when the kids are young
when they get older i'm gonna move i'm
gonna get out of a relationship
the most damage is done from zero to two
months
because that's the time when the brain
is taking in everything
and anybody who's ever had children you
all know this because
you get to watch that whole language
socialization process
how do they learn the word dada how did
they learn mama
how do they learn spoon how did they
learn so as they're taking in
all of that when the brain is the most
open and receptive
they're also taking in all the other
stuff
that changed everything for me in terms
of
how people are raising their kids and
how we see
that what you do in front of the
youngest children matters
you know i have a question um which is
that uh when when i was born my dad
he had split with my mom and um i
i just didn't know him he was very
abusive he would come around he would
trash the house
uh he was scary um
and you know there are a lot of people
and you share um a story of what
happened
the first night that you stayed with
your mom in milwaukee
and for people who have
um had a parent one or two
that did not want to be in their child's
lives for whatever their reasons were
which is
valid to them very hard for a child to
understand
what do you talk through with yourself
or other people who have had that kind
of start
to their lives who deal with that kind
of trauma
you talk about the eyes and the being
wanted and the being set up right
what happens when you're not so here's
the
here's the good news about all of this
because all of us have had things to
happen to our and not to happen to us
in our lives that caused us to feel
unwanted and
not important everybody has at some
point in your life
even if you come from the best of
circumstances
it is possible to take your
post-traumatic
pain and turn that into post-traumatic
power and post-traumatic wisdom i know
this for sure that whatever has happened
to you
can also be for you
if you allow it to be the thing that has
healed me the most
is taking the pain that i endured
suffered survived as a child and turning
that inside out
so that is why i created my school
specifically looking for girls who were
just like me
who came from poor backgrounds who came
from dysfunctional backgrounds
who many times felt unwanted unloved
how do i create an environment for them
how do i give
back this is how you save yourself how
do i give
back that which i was not given
and when you can do that you begin to
fill the hole inside yourself
that giving back has become
really what my legacy is and i i will
share this with you that i was sitting
with maya angelou
after i'd come back from the opening of
my school and i said oh this is going to
be the school this is going to be my
greatest legacy
i mean these girls this is this is this
is this is what my life was for and she
said you have no idea
what your legacy will be and i said oh
no no no no my you she should have been
there it's i'm telling you that's going
to be the school
and she said i said you have no idea
what your legacy will be your legacy is
every life you touch your legacy isn't
your name on a school or any other
building
your legacy is every life you touch so i
say this to you drew barrymore
your legacy this is what maya said to me
everybody who's ever watched a show
and decided i'm going to go back to
school i'm going to go on a diet
i'm going to treat myself better i'm
going to leave an abusive relationship
every life that you have touched
that has experienced your voice and the
power of your platform
that is your legacy
and that is why in oprah we trust and i
just want to say
also that you said here's the good news
that to me is one of the most positive
and powerful ways in which to engage
people's minds and hearts
because it is so hopeful we're going to
take a quick commercial break when we
come back we're going to continue this
conversation
the co-author of what happened to you dr
bruce perry will be with us we'll be
right back
welcome back we are here with oprah
winfrey and joining us as one of the
leading authorities on
brain trauma and the founder of the
child trauma academy
he is the co-author of what happened to
you it's dr bruce perry hello dr perry
hi drew hi oprah hey dr perry
good to see you again i was listening
and i have to say
isn't that oh w something unbelievable
yes well i think that the fact that you
teamed up
speaks volumes um to and about each of
you
and dr perry you've been an expert on
childhood development and the impacts of
trauma on our brain
for the past 30 years and they say that
there's like a misconception that trauma
is this big unwelcome tragic event in
our lives but
do you think that it has to be big or
can it be
moments throughout everybody has a
journey
and on that journey there's just no way
that you
you're going to get through that
unscathed so and
as you say it doesn't always have to be
this big catastrophic disaster that
everybody would point to and go oh
that's trauma
yes exactly more often it's smaller
things right i mean
it's the things in it in oprah and i've
talked about this a lot we talk about
this in the book but
one of the most important things about
being a human being is
is feeling like you belong like you
belong in your family you belong in your
community
you belong in your culture and if you
get signals from your parents
or you get signals from your classmates
that you don't belong
and those signals might come from
something like
their implicit bias that you're the
wrong religion or you're the wrong
skin color or you have the wrong
ethnicity and if you get these non-stop
little stressors that you have no
control over
over time that changes the systems in
your body that control stress
and and it can really have profound
impact on your mental health and on your
physical health
and when it comes to the brain can we
rebuild what wasn't there
can we regulate relate and reason yeah
well the good news is that the brain is
changeable
and if given opportunities
with sufficient uh repetition
these systems in our brain that have
been impacted by our past experiences
they can begin to normalize
and become more typically regulated and
ultimately
you can heal oprah said something about
how there is good news
and we can take the holes that have been
given
and bestowed upon us in our life and
make them our strength
make them the cues in which how we
treat other people um
has there been a point oprah in your
life
where somebody else had to fill those
holes i think
for me that would those were teachers i
wouldn't be who i am that's what that is
why i have such a love for teachers i
mean if somebody tells me a teacher i
literally start like
you're a teacher because in my life
teachers were my saviors when i went to
school
i was important and that is where my
sense of
self and worthiness came from
not from my family but from other people
and so
bruce said and this is true of all of us
nobody makes it out here alone
and our connectedness to other people
our relationships with people who can
see us all you need is
one person who fully sees you
and believes and that's the thing that
you hold on to
that you are seeing you are valued and
that you matter
and i i what i realized i didn't even
share this with you dr perry
what i realized is that
gail was my regulation makes me want to
cry now thinking about it
every night after the show i would come
home
and i would have these you know sessions
with gail where he talked about what
happened on the show or didn't happen on
the show donna
and that was the way i kind of regulated
myself so
i would talk to gail before bed and then
i would be calmer
and it wasn't until i not only was
co-authoring the book but actually went
back and re-read the book
that i realized oh gail was what i use
for my sense of regulation
and is still the person in my life i
have
probably three people in my life who are
going to tell me the truth no matter
what
i thank you both so much for your time
and i love this book so very much
um what happened to you by oprah winfrey
and dr bruce perry
is out now available everywhere books
are sold and each one
of our vffs will be receiving a copy of
this book
i want to just say that dr perry and i
have been
also for the past two years along with
prince harry
and apple we've been working on this
mental health series
um that's coming out in may on apple
and you know what our mental well-being
our mental health being able to rise to
the best of yourself is a part of
my goal in life and now as i you know
get to spend my days doing exactly what
i want to do
i mean i still continue to be uh the
kind of
the kind of person who wants to use my
life
in order to help other people have the
best of theirs because i think i have
just the best life ever
and i think that that that comes from
doing the work peeling back the layers
and that certainly begins with looking
at what happened to you so
thank you for an opportunity to talk
about it and to share it with other
people
thank you and look at the conversation
you had with megan and prince harry i
believe that will change the world and
it will change the future
so with each conversation may you make
history as well
well thank you for changing the future
thanks to oprah and dr perry
and if you'd like to attend oprah and dr
perry's virtual book tour
visit our website at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com for all the
information you need
thank you so much thank you guys we'll
be right back
welcome back our next guest is a james
beard award winner
co-host of netflix's the chef show
and author of one of my favorite
cookbooks ever la sun my life my city my
food
he is the chef and founder of koji
barbecue the godfather of the food truck
movement
someone who is an incredible
philanthropist and really shows
what's possible in the culinary world as
far as taking care of people
as a girl who grew up in los angeles
this man has my heart he always had he's
always well
ladies and gentlemen i'm about to have a
bucket list moment because it's roy choi
hey drew you are one of my favorite
chefs
on this planet i'm actually like
melting over here thank you you deserve
to be i've been such a fan of yours for
years okay
i'm so excited by the way i'm i'm going
to show a picture
this is my kitchen by the way um this is
some of my cookbook collection your
cookbook la sun
and these are all your sauces and i have
to say
roy choi you've done it once again they
were the best sauces i've ever
had in my life and
funny enough i combined two in the dish
because i was slurping it up and they
all started to run together
first they were neatly in their corners
and as i grazed it all
coagulated and salivating that's so
awesome that's exactly i mean you did
exactly what i want
wanted folks to do with these sauces
because we created these sauces
to be almost like crayons you know like
you could do anything you want with them
they're really easy you just pour them
together you make your own sauce
out of the sauces and that was the whole
idea behind everything and i'll show you
how easy it is
so the first one is the korean bbq
marinade so for you as a cook all you
gotta do is pour it over
you just pour it over and mix it um
so i think you already have some cooking
over there i had some going already but
i want to show you
so this is the i just poured this over
right now and then this is after a
couple hours
right here and you see how it's broken
down and then what we want to do is just
put that right on the griddle
um but yeah so you just want to grill
this up and then as it's grilling you
want to add these onions and cilantro
so this is just chopped onions chopped
cilantro lime juice and a little bit of
salt
oh my gosh this smells so good
great right does it doesn't smell
amazing perfect i'm right there with you
and then so now we're going to let that
kind of do its thing
and we're going to move over and we're
going to start our quesadilla here
okay put the quesadilla on the griddle
or the pan
and then go ahead um and then go ahead
and layer your cheese over the top
we'll do a nice generous layer you know
i like food messy
thank god it's okay to go around the
edges almost
almost i encourage going outside the
lines
you know here and just letting it kind
of like
fall off the edges so you got to keep an
eye on your tortilla what we're looking
for
here is obviously you want the cheese to
melt but what we want
on the bottom here we want to create
these blisters within the tortilla
and then now what we're going to do take
that cooked meat
and let's go over one side of it kind of
like a half
moon and then now once you do that we're
gonna flip it over
and then once you flip it give it a nice
press
we're gonna flip it
look at you every time you flip it i
want you to give it a little press give
it a little love press
like that
yeah i'm spanking mine again keep
pressing it
and then now we're almost ready let's go
over to the cutting board look at that
okay we're gonna go to the cutting board
and then at the cutting board
we're gonna we're gonna cut this thing
into four slices so just cut right down
the middle
and then cut the the halves again
oh you're doing great you're doing
fantastic look at that
there you go and just think pizza slices
oh my gosh
so there you go and then what we want to
do
is we have our orange chili sauce and
just drizzle right over the top
just drizzle over the top i'm going a
little jackson pollock splatter art i
don't know why
there you go and then you can you can
garnish if you'd like
with some cilantro and then that's your
kogi short rib sweet chili
quesadilla now is it okay if i taste
this yes
oh my god thank you oh my god that's it
look how beautiful that is
thank you so much roy joy
you have been my hero since i was hold
on
i love your food so much roy choi it is
an honor and a pleasure
to finally make your acquaintance as a
huge fan and an
la girl oh my gosh thank you so much
for this recipe and to get your koji
sauces which will change your life go to
thedrewbermarshow.com
roy choi it is an honor let this be the
first of many thank you thank you thank
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back it's time for drew's news
your good news puppy dog that always
brings in that good newspaper
and look me at the desk is a man who
does an excellent dog impression ross
matthew oh hi
i think my i think my dog impression's a
little rough
[Laughter]
first order of business ross stain
claims
yep we're in this was yesterday right
just yesterday
and we learned about this hashtag pink
stuff the magical tub of cleaning goop
taking over tick tock so we all have on
here
some crayon some marker and i said
listen
you gotta throw some spaghetti sauce on
there because that is a real stain test
for me
so i've never tried this so i don't
really know what i'm up against
okay you love a stain though more than
anything
okay it's really working this is very
exciting
i mean look at my face frosty i'm
looking at you you've never been happier
about anything
look at that it's all gone hello
yeah thank you everybody um
i i know are you satisfied
[Laughter]
all right well i know what i'm doing
with the rest of my life
okay we have an icon in the wings okay
is this really happening because i heard
someone was going to be here and i can't
even wrap my little head around it
we've been asking her for a while
because we're such huge fans of hers
for everything she's done in her life
and
also the really fun world she's created
on twitter that just has
everybody on the twitter feeder and on
her highly trafficked twitter account
she is as we know the big bridger tin
fan
and she has been demanding the return
of the duke please welcome someone we
have been
waiting with anticipation and having the
pleasure and the honor of speaking with
please welcome icon six time grammy
award winner and the queen of
twitterverse now
dion warwick the legend
we know that you are our sister in
bridgerton hood right
uh and uh a topic near and dear dear to
your heart
is reggae john page uh gq says the
dashing duke
should be the next james bond
uh i'd watch that someone needs to take
over for daniel craig
he's retiring from bond after his fourth
and final uh double o7 film
no time to die and um reggae is
in the mix do you think he'd make a good
one honey as far as i can say he can do
anything you want i
totally agree now there are other names
in the mix let's see there's a michael b
jordan who would be great too right
harry styles is in the mix what do you
think of harry styles
no
well i feel like i love the other male
ideas but i'm still voting for reggae
jean paige
dionne what do you think yeah that's a
bit of had a heartbeat right there you
know what i'm saying
i do i've always been with james brown
represented that
sex symbol but still swab and
yeah yeah there was one of the name too
i want to get your opinion on idris elba
absolutely incredible yeah he's another
heart drop
you know i saw him once outside of the
golden globes and he was like
he needed his car that's like my one in
this other story he was like i need the
car
we gotta get in the car see that's
already that makes a good bond
he's got somewhere to go gotta get in
the car kind of like crime dissolved
of course i wanted to like stop and chat
with him but i was like he really seems
like he needs to get somewhere so i'm
not
gonna annoy him right now but i was
freaking out that i was next to
interstellar but this was like
i don't know 12 years ago you were
rubbing elbas
yes i was i i had the pleasure of
meeting him at
uh the premiere of one of his films i
can't remember the name of the film
in fact and i met his daughter so i met
his fiancee at the time
uh oh i said charming young man true
i love him okay next story we are
talking the latest
in wedding fashion the new bridal trend
popping up on the internet is
the bridal bucket hat it's the bucket
hat
the 90s movie made famous but in wedding
white
instead i don't know why the 90s movies
made this famous i think fishermen made
this face
yeah it's a little like fish stick dion
i would love to get your take on this
um i don't know why any pride especially
right
wants to look like a fisherman the bell
is the mystery you know that is the
mysterious part of being a bride when
nobody really sees they anticipate
that lifting of the veils see that
beautiful face
i'm getting married soon do you think i
should wear a veil oh no
understood thank you all right write
that down for me okay
dion you've spread so much joy this year
over twitter
and now we're going to get even more
dion in a live stream
concert event is this right yes that's
right
mother's day may 9th it's going to be a
wonderful wonderful evening we did one
for easter
and that that went over exceptionally
well we had a lot of fun people
appreciated it and they
missed the music as i do
so mother's day may 9th google dion
warwick doug mandolin
and we'll all spend the afternoon and
evening together
i'll be there we cannot wait for that
thank you dion warwick for finally
joining us here on the show where there
is just nothing but love for you
thank you appreciate that
and you guys take good care of
yourselves please
welcome back before we go i've got one
quick pick
from our little yellow book and that is
our list of stuff that we love
and want to share with you and we
refresh it all the time it's on our
website
and today it's all the snuggly goodness
you can get
at barefoot dreams
now listen this is a family-owned
business based out of malibu california
that makes the comfiest and coziest
blankets
and sleepwear and robes and apparel for
kids
and i have one of these blankets one
and my kids and i fight over it and i
have to tell you
you will never feel anything like this
this is like a hybrid
coziest blanket slash like fluffiest
towel you've ever
felt you know i don't know how they do
it
but the good news is they do and it is
the
perfect mother's day gift but as a
special gift
to our amazing vff's guess what you are
all getting
300 what to spend at barefoot hey
and then you and your family members can
fight over it
so much thank you for spending time with
us and we will see you very soon
barefoot dream it's kind of chic how you
have it draped on your shoulder
you